vamos con nuestro invitado del día y es
que las elecciones de medio término
siguen arrojando resultados y el proceso
continuará por varios días pero de
momento la Euforia republicana ha bajado
el volumen Pues si bien podrían ser
mayoría en la cámara esta no sería una
mayoría imponente y en el senado aún hay
mucho por definirse Vamos a darle
entonces la bienvenida a nuestro
invitado de esta mañana con la primera
pregunta qué pasó Por qué no llegó esta
esperada marea roja
Saludos Ángel a un placer estar contigo
y con el francés 24
Mira una victoria es una victoria Sin
lugar a duda uno pues
quiere siempre ganar y ganar en grande
una sobredosis de de Victoria no es
verdad Pero la realidad es que con un
con un punto se gana en el caso de la
cámara baja los republicanos van a tener
una mayoría Clara y en la cámara alta
pues es probable después que se vayan
algunas contiendas a la a lo que se
llama un gronoff el balotaje
Considero que ganarán porque había un
tercer candidato por ejemplo en el caso
de Georgia libertario que más bien le
quitó votos al candidato
republicano pero hubo sorpresas de
muchas cosas por ejemplo
negacionista de elecciones se stacrons
la demócrata en Georgia perdió incluso
mucho más grande de lo que yo pensé que
iba a perder en para el escaño de
Gobernador en el estado de Georgia ganó
el inconveniente Camp por otro lado por
ejemplo en estado como Pensilvania si os
perdió por un margen más más grande o
sea que en ese sentido hubo
sorpresas pero sin lugar a duda el
presidente biden no va a tener en los
próximos dos años
el espacio que tuvo en su primera mitad
de administración
Julio chilling ustedes politólogos
escritores estratega republicano y pues
aquí hay que dar y hay que recibir hay
que empezar a hacer ese balance no
en estos resultados apretados que
podrían dar un liderazgo muy cerrado en
la cámara qué significaría esto para la
agenda legislativa republicana
Bueno mira hay que recordar muchos
demócratas o sea
ven lo que está ocurriendo y hay que
entender que por ejemplo un Distrito
como Alexandra
Ocasio Ortega Cortés tiene pues una base
sólida en apoyo a una visión más de
izquierda sin embargo hay demócratas que
son entre distritos más moderados Y
entonces es en ese caso donde podemos
encontrar en determinadas medidas que
romperán con el el centralismo
democrático digamos que quisiera
mantener la la presidenta de la cámara
en Nancy pelosi Sí pues continúa en ese
en ese puesto o sea los republicanos
obtuvieron una
mayoría Y eso se ampliará en la cámara
en la cámara baja que normalmente
que siempre es territorio cómodo para
los demócratas Y en este caso no no fue
Bueno pero pero pero pues siendo más
hacia hacia el fondo de la cuestión
ustedes cree que esto será un
impedimento para que continúen
impulsando una muy clara agenda
republicana que hemos visto en los
últimos meses o diríamos en el último
año
Mira tenemos que entender por ejemplo la
inflación el crimen
la crisis en la frontera Sur que tiene
que ver con no solo la entrada
de personas fuera de de violando las
leyes de inmigración de los Estados
Unidos sino la droga 90% de la droga que
entra a los Estados Unidos entra por la
frontera sur y Estos son problemas que
impactan demócratas y republicanos
blancos y negros hombres y mujeres y es
ahí donde Pues precisamente muchos
demócratas van a que de hecho lo vimos
durante la contienda que se distanciaron
por ejemplo del presidente
es más le pidieron directamente que ni
fuera por su en que estuvieran y se
acercara su campaña de modo de que la no
podemos mal interpretar y decir el hecho
de que hayan habido varias sorpresas y
que demócratas podemos decir hicieron un
mejor de lo que se esperaba que eso
quiere decir que hay una aprobación de
El Camino Hacia dónde va el país eso no
es el caso la inflación en uno solo está
al ocho y pico por ciento eso es un
promedio hay artículos por ejemplo que
están al más del 30% de inflación eso
impacta a las personas
de menor recursos más que nadie de modo
de que es eso es una realidad y los
candidatos que más sepan representar una
solución hacia eso pues tendrán el apoyo
de los estadounidenses julio y Bueno
hablemos de lo que ha sido calificado
por medios internacionales como una mala
noche de para Donald Trump Usted qué
opina de esto sigue siendo una figura
dominante en el partido pero Pero
estaría en riesgo su candidatura para
Mira el problema que los Estados Unidos
tiene o sea hay dos
digamos dos sistemas están las primarias
y después están las elecciones generales
en las primarias 90% de los candidatos
que dan Trump apoyó ganaron en las
primarias quiere decir eso las primarias
son elecciones donde los votantes de un
partido eligen Quién quiere que le
representa las elecciones generales es
otro animal ya es mucho más
inclusivo porque incluye ya a toda la
población
Donald Trump o sea es una es una figura
que sin lugar a duda si él decide
postularse No creo que por ejemplo el
gobernador de la Florida Randy sandis
que apunta a hacer la la próxima
estrella del partido republicano se va a
postular si la pregunta es si Donald
Trump Yo creo que es una figura po Sí yo
creo que eso queda
polémica mucho más en el sentido del
país en general por su Estilo por su
expresiones etcétera Pero dentro de el
partido republicano tiene un apoyo
impresionante